little box opening okay shout out to the
boy pay money man
yeah what a fantastic video he made i
was
i mean i messaged him this but i was
howling
so funny so funny it's so [ __ ] funny
to make
fun of skeezy dudes like that i do
everything like when you just pause it
and go just hold up why is this dude's
head
so shiny and he's like why is it so
shiny
and then dude i watch it twice right
yeah the first time i was kind of half
watching it and the second time i really
watched it and like
oh my god his reactions are just so
blatantly obvious what's going through
his head
yeah yeah not not pay money i mean the
guy
right yeah on the live stream yeah tell
so tell the people the background
yeah so basically pay money
uncovered more or less that um
the guy that logan paul bought
he bought a box set of pokemon cards the
one that he opened on stream when he had
all those viewers and blah blah blah
the dude he bought that box set from is
like a scammer
and it's crazy how everybody missed that
part the funniest part to me is this
dude showed up and pulled the box set
out of a gucci bag yeah
yeah i thought it was ridiculous if
there's something i never want to see if
i'm buying
something like that i don't want the
seller to
try in any way to be cool yeah
i want the i want the nerdiest yeah i
want thankiest
yeah i want someone who seems like they
don't go outside yeah
they eat breathe and [ __ ] pokemon you
better have a dusty pokemonster with pit
dirt that's what i was gonna say it's
the backpack should be a giant pikachu
yeah like that he's that he's zipping
open yeah he's taking the box yeah right
yeah yeah
yeah at if there is any backpack yeah
otherwise
i want him to come in head down so i can
see his bald spot
and he lumbers over yeah and and
i could smell the mountain dew off him
and then he goes
it took a lot of work to get this one
i'm like thank you bro yeah thank you
yes you got to wipe cheez-it dust off
the top yeah yeah what is that
a little bit of what is that and he goes
like this to his hands sweat sorry
actually no i feel like a devout pokemon
collector wouldn't do that they'd be
dirty everywhere but the hands the hands
would be gloved up gloved up yeah yeah
for sure well that was another thing
about
like the oh yeah he's just this guy
clearly doesn't give a [ __ ] because like
on another stream where he was opening
like the rarest box of all time or the
most expensive boxer of all time
he's like yeah i forgot i forgot sleeves
for the cards so i'm just putting them
in plastic bags yeah and they're like
what you clearly don't give a [ __ ] about
this no
no um so anyways keep going
now he's a scammer sorry my brain is
spiraling now on this
stereotype of a pokemon collector what
else are you thinking
now i'm thinking they're not dirty at
all because if they care about cars that
much they're probably like
their house is like a hospital oh i see
what you're saying yeah
they don't want to breathe sneeze they
want to keep that they probably keep
their house at a certain temperature
yeah i don't think it's like it's not
like
cigars though like they're not they're
not that careful about them i don't
think like a lot of them
have them on like their shelves like in
their rooms yeah it's true they're not
like
in a safe they're just sitting there
unless you buy from this guy
yeah anyway so this dude who sold logan
paul the boxset
he's a scammer he's a known scammer in
the community and during logan paul's
stream he's just sort of throwing out
valuations of cards that just really
aren't real
and logan paul is just kind of buying
into it right he says oh man i pulled
this how much
does this go for he said oh man 20 30
grand
it's such a huge discrepancy bro yeah
and
there's there are two organizations that
grade
cards right yeah to determine
you know the quality whatever so this
guy goes on to
sell a box set to some actual
millionaires what's their channel called
dumb money dumb dub money or something
like that yeah
it's it's a couple guys that have a [ __ ]
load of cash and they do youtube on the
side and
about investing about how to spend your
money so they get into pokemon they know
nothing about it so
they're like this guy looks like a good
investment yeah yeah and and he has
they have this atrocious live stream
where they do the deal live
and the scammer shows up with this box
and he goes oh you want to open it now
and then they say yeah you know we might
as well and they bring these two pokemon
you know collectors who are just all
about it the kinds of guys you want
you know vetting the cards and
the scammer immediately goes all right
well
and he just starts telegraphing if
this is fake or if this was a scam
typically how they do it so we're going
to find out
sellers totally go blah blah he's just
telling on himself which is like
why would you even bring that up in that
situation
yeah if you didn't know with 100
certainty that it's about to happen
yeah if you really believed in yourself
and your product why would you bring
that up in that
in that moment yeah like ah wait before
we do this i didn't know we were going
to open it
if it is a scam it's not my fault all
right
it's their fault so they open it
and sure enough it's [ __ ] fake voila
yeah and they spent like what three
hundred thousand bucks on this
supposedly
375 grand yeah and it's fake
yeah and so the guy and they're on live
stream so it's really [ __ ] awkward
and the guys are trying not to be like
really blaming i guess and the guy was
like i'm gonna go get a new box i'm
gonna call the guy right now and then he
like hops on the phone on the live
stream and the guy picks up in like
a second so like the whole conversation
was probably fake
yeah yeah he like fakes a phone
conversation on the live stream
it is awesome dude yeah get [ __ ] and
then he
then he dm's pay money yeah let me read
this this is the best part
this is the type of dude this guy is
dude right i went in rez actually pull
it up on the computer
i went actually no i went and read some
of the comments
that he was responding to yeah oh bro
the salt
really the salt so this is what he said
he collectibles guru is the guy's name
he
dm'd pay money and said are you the fat
youtuber who goes out of his way to
create drama
when i'm the one out 55k right now and
225k
profit now he's a victim
yeah get out of here man bro i went to
his instagram
oh he's a [ __ ] god he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you gotta look the part to be the part
yeah
hold on yeah i gotta pull up one of
these on this guy's post
okay okay okay this is [ __ ] awesome
oh my god this is so good you got to
pull this up on there yeah all right
all right because everyone needs to see
this
everyone honestly this dude deserves
all of this [ __ ] what in the i'm
literally anytime that happens
yeah i'm i swore i muted this anyway
yeah yeah oh this post this post right
here
you have to be a doctor or a lawyer to
make dollar signs
laughing emojis my haters can say
whatever they want
the reality is keyboard warriors don't
do 375k
plus deals with celebrities weekly
jealousy is an unfortunate thing make it
drive you hard
weekly such a funny flex y'all not doing
deals with celebs
weekly do you guys do deals how many
deals are you doing with celebs by the
way
zero man zero yeah i'm doing them weekly
oh wow
wow damn not what it's not enough that
you're doing 375
000 deals a week why
why with celebs like who gives a [ __ ]
who cares weekly homie
[Laughter]
this dude going to johnny depp's house
let's come in
i was i was wondering when you would
arrive
and then he'd [ __ ] i don't even know
this guy's voice what's his what's
what does this guy sound like um sounds
like this no i don't know he calls
himself the crypto king
yeah so he's super into crypto and
pokemon which is like dude yeah come on
come on like come on yeah
if there was if there was a like um you
know uh
pick this or like a paint by numbers for
you to look like a scammer yeah it would
be crypto and pokemon guards
bro his head really is bumpy
oh what kind of he looks like that it's
like a
there's a whale that has this same head
shape
you know what i'm talking about i don't
know enough about
uh beluga whale
[Laughter]
dude get the [ __ ] out of here that's his
head
that is his head dude
i feel bad because it's like no what if
he's not a scammer no he probably is
right
yes okay okay dude absolutely i know you
could not the problem with
with like commentary videos you can
really paint them the way that you want
to paint them
but if i were to watch that live stream
no yeah
come on out of context i'd be like this
guy is trying to scam these
come on dude if you're not a scammer
you you double down and diss everyone
was calling you out no if if that's
legit you make a video and you go hey
or in my opinion you would naturally you
you would be offended that your
integrity was in question yeah
so you would you say hey listen yeah
yeah i swear to god i bought this fair
and square and here's the messages i
agree with you and you also wouldn't dm
a dude and call him
the fat youtuber that starts drama
that's like the most
absurd [ __ ] dog that's the most 12
year old [ __ ]
why are you starting drama fool why you
strong why are you starting drama fatty
huh are you the little fat chunky boy
that's starting up drama when i'm doing
deals with celebs weekly
i was at [ __ ] matt damon's house last
week
selling him some ethereum bro you don't
even know how many pokemon cards the
rock has
oh yeah you thought this was crazy the
rocks going ape [ __ ] on pokemon cards
i'm gonna open a charizard yeah
i'm at his i'm at his place by monthly
month doing deals with him
you know you know that post he did where
he ripped his gate off and he was like
there's 60 000 in there for me yeah
hello who do you think that was on the
inside of the house yeah yeah
waiting to close i'm on a holographic
mewtwo
i'm brokering a deal for him it's me
inside
okay i'm doing this on the regular dog
yeah
it's [ __ ] this this peace gesture dog
i think that bodes low confidence this
yeah yeah it's it's a i don't know it's
a weird
it's a it's a yeah i don't know what to
do what was the soup deuce again
soup deuce soup deuce was no soup juice
was up oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah super what was that
soup deuce why was it called soup
because you're super
super duper super deuce can't remember
why we called it that soup
folks jogger memories on the soup dudes
oh yeah kyle bring it yeah
you're gonna get us cancelled bro why
yes
apparently yeah no no it's dasani it's
dasani